Are there ways to lower one's blood pressure naturally? I can't take blood thinning meds or
supplements. I have a pacemaker and the heart rate is usually in good range. So lowering one's
blood pressure, yes, there's a lot of different things that you could take for lowering your blood
pressure. Now, the issue is, remember, if you also have cancer, then some of those things you have
to at least take an account. So one of the better things to, there's a lot of different herbs that
could lower blood pressure like Hawthorne and Valerian root and different things like that.
We have nutrition out there that one's supplements, probably our best-selling supplement
from restorative formulas is HTN complexes, HTN something, you just search HTN at our store.
They have an extra strength and a regular strength that has got some of those herbs in it.
But one of the quickest ways to lower one's blood pressure is using nitric oxide supplements. So
nitric oxide could help bind to the smooth muscle receptors in the smooth muscles that lie right underneath
the endothelial cells, the light of the vessels, and it's those smooth muscles that are in a state of
contraction with somebody who has high blood pressure. So the definition of high blood pressure
is contraction of the smooth muscles that lie in the endothelial cells because that makes the
lubit of the vessel smaller and the pressure going through there is faster. So if I had a great big
pipe and I only have so much water going through it, pressure's going to be real slow. But if I
shrink my pipe to a half inch pipe diameter, the water's going to be racing through there. That's what
blood pressure is. So the problem with nitric oxide supplements, so if the person came to me they didn't
they didn't have cancer and they had high blood pressure. We go on a nitric oxide supplement.
I put them on herbal supplements too, but that's the fastest way to deal with that. Plus you want to
deal with H. Pylori because that's probably the most common reason why the smooth muscles are in
contraction of the first place. But nitric oxide will open up those vessels. But nitric oxide also
increases vascular endothelial growth factor and you don't want that for cancer. So I would do
if I had a diagnosis of cancer and I wasn't in remission and I had high blood pressure, I would go
with the urban route first.